moin biane dan hier meine Frage bezieht
sich nicht direkt auf Schulstress weil
ich mich nicht mit Schulstress auskenne
weil ich mich nie von der Schule habe
stressen lassen ich lasse mich nur von
mir selbst stressen von daher bezieht
sich meine Frage eher so auf andere
Dinge in der Schulzeit und zwar auf das
schönste und das schlimmste Erlebnis
dass du jemals hattest und dass dir auf
ewig im Gedächtnis bleiben wird mein
schlimmstes Erlebnis hat z.B mein
komplettes Leben verändert aber ins
Positive im
Nachhinein also welches ist dein
schlimmstes Erlebnis und welches ist
dein schönstes und noch was ganz unter
uns Mädels es erfährt uns keiner wie
viele Tafeln Schokolade sind beim leen
für deine Abiprüfung drauf gegangen war
do
schon ja also mein schönstes Erlebnis in
der Schule war der Ausgang von mein
Abiprüfung als ich dann wirklich das
Zeugnis dann in den Händen hatte und den
Abiprüfung die sind bei mir sehr gut
ausgefallen von da habe ich mich da
total drüber gefreut und bin auch
erstmal ein bisschen rumgesprungen
das Schlimmste Erlebnis ja gut was war
das da gab schon paar ich glaube wenn
man mal wieder eine total willkürliche
Note in Empfang genommen hat das war
schon ja wo man gedacht hat wo was soll
das jetzt z.B in Deutsch hatte ich so
ein Vertretungslehrer der hat dann
plötzlich die Klausuren ganz anderes
ganz anders bewertet und dann hatte ich
dann plötzlich drei Minus in Deutsch was
dann auch mein Abis Schnitt da ein
bisschen runtergezogen hat ja das war
mit unter kein schönes Erlebnis ja die
Schokolade ja ja da weiß ich gar nicht
wie viele Tafeln Schokolade ich für die
Abi Prüfung da gegessen habe um mich da
zu konzentrieren irgendwie ich glaube
das waren schon etliche aber ich habe da
nicht mitgezählt ich glaube das wä dann
auch gar nicht so gut gewesen hätte ich
das zäht wie viel Kalorien ich da
verspeist habe ja hätte man sich glaube
ich im Nachhinein geärgert von daher
lieber nicht
zählen